so this is how the Borg started
[Music]
transcendence
so transcendence is a movie starring
Johnny Depp is directed by one of
Christopher Nolan's cinematographers
it's written by a guy who wrote that one
movie transcendence seriously that's it
it's all he wrote and Johnny Depp plays
one of many people are trying to make an
AI artificial intelligence but there's
this group they're like nah analogs
awesome bring back my space as I shoot
Johnny Depp and his wife's like Oh
before he dies we could upload his
consciousness onto a computer because
ultimately electrical signals and [ __ ]
we all saw hackers in the 90s so we buy
that and now Johnny Depp is Max Headroom
only thing is right after Johnny Depp
becomes this computer he's like hey can
you plug me into Wall Street bank
accounts Internet I just need more power
right and flags start going up so Paul
Bettany is like it's not good and his
wife's like yeah it is so it's this
whole thing we're so good Johnny Depp
gonna be an [ __ ] now he's a super
computer the odds are yes he is which is
a sweet concept even in the movie it had
sweet parts I mean it being directed by
a cinematographer you look at it you're
like oh that's nice that looks neat the
problem is when they go to podunk
nowhere seriously they go to this town
that's like Arnold Schwarzenegger a
sheriff of this town kind of thing the
movie slows if a movie like this is
gonna put on the brakes for you to have
thought-provoking moments and be like
okay stops not really happening but it
leaves you time to contemplate that be
one thing but no it's ultimately it's
like Johnny Depp is making these people
better with nanobots and other people
are like oh he's going too far we got to
put a stop to him they create this
convoluted plan that is fine until you
leave the movie theater and you're like
no no that doesn't make any sense
ultimately the movie becomes a mess
after the movie looked like it was gonna
be awesome the movie spans a couple
years it didn't feel like it needed to
span a couple of years just one more
thing to gripe about right now the movie
had entertaining parts and it does leave
you with that oh that was interesting
let's think about it which you can tell
the movie wants you to contemplate it
after you leave the movie theater but
when you do you just start picking the
movie apart which isn't good it's like
the movie
to think about the movie is actually
working against the movie it'd be better
if the movie was like here cut and dry
nothing to think about but instead
you're like oh let's think about that is
that well that was interesting it
started out good well wait a minute that
doesn't really make sense like that that
doesn't make sense and then you start
picking the thing apart till there's
nothing left you just dissect the [ __ ]
out of it you can tell this movie wanted
you to feel like it's like oh [ __ ]
a is gonna take over it's like the
beginning of the Terminator future war
but ultimately it turns out to be the
beginning of the Terminator war if it
was a cold war I enjoyed parts of it
enough but I would never elect to watch
the movie again which means ultimately
and disappointingly transcendence would
be a good time if you're drunk yes now
what is a party these are all fresh new
people doing this movie it's like a
first time director and a first time
writer this is like that dare to be
great situation that wasn't that great
but so what is the coolest AI robot ever
that is a lot of sci-fi to cover my
friends whichever robot holds closest to
your heart whoever he is whoever she is
comment below let me know that's right
robots have genders now apparently and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you